all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back again with
invincible a little late on our upload
today but i kind of had a lot going on
this morning so i didn't get it recorded
on time but here is the thing in the
last video we basically ended with as
you guys love calling him freddie
mercury but technically his name is
thrag
the emperor of the viltromite empire but
this guy was getting ready to take on
nolan and mark right omniman and mark
and the reason why is because they were
basically part of the whole faction that
destroyed his world right that the
coalition of planets had essentially
obliterated the viltrumite world in an
effort to basically end the reign of the
vulture mites now a lot of this was
because with no home planet to go back
to anybody that was there on that world
at the time was gone right they were
completely and totally destroyed and so
now they're basically homeless in the
vastness of the universe not only that
it was a moral blow because they were
able to destroy the viltrumide empire
this really drove a lot of the races out
there that were previously conscripted
by the uh by the viltrumites to actually
turn against the viltrumites and join
the cause of the coalitional planet so
it was as much a a moral victory as it
was a real battle victory but again it
was only a small conflict in this
viltrumite war because following that
thrag is pissed now nolan does know
about thrag right but he's not he's not
dumbing anything from mark right mark
immediately goes in to attack thrag and
he's like you killed my brother he goes
to punch him in the head and nothing
happens like literally doesn't draw
blood drag doesn't even say ouch right
it's nothing he immediately grabs mark
and literally just starts pummeling this
guy smashes the sides of his head this
fight was over before it even started
right i mean this kid has no earthly
chance like no possible chance against
somebody like thrag now at that point
nolan steps in but even then nolan is a
half measure here it's a crazy thing
because like as they're fighting at the
end of the day like like thrax like okay
so you really sided with thaddeus right
you you are aware that thaddeus was the
one who killed who basically set the
viltrumide empire into a state of
disarray and that's one of the things we
talked about before remember when it
came to the power or the the role the
villager mites played initially they
were a huge expansive conquering race
but the scourge virus was developed by
thaddeus using his own dna as a means to
destroy the viltrumite race because in
the mind of thaddeus they were they were
horrible right their place their role in
the the universe and all of creation was
bad and they needed to be destroyed and
so the result of this is that it's
because of the actions of thrag that
lord argol died in the first place the
entire empire had been sent into
disarray any possible air taking over
the throne after lord argol was
basically gone and so thrag was
essentially just kind of put in this
place instead as the regent but at the
end of the day the response of nolan
based on everything he's experienced
right having been on earth facing off
against mark going on to become a hero
different things like that because
assault basically changed him and turned
him into a good guy the response he has
here is our race deserves to die because
of the things that we've done and
because of how we've harmed people we
don't deserve to live here right we
don't deserve to exist our actions are
horrible the things we've done have been
terrible so like our race deserves to
die and for that he's immediately
attached by thrive because it's taken as
what is in effect heresy right now in
the middle of this great big huge battle
where where omni man is just getting
absolutely thrashed in comes battle
beast right now as you guys know battle
beast only really cares about the lust
of the battle right the less of the
conflict he just wants to attack whoever
right anybody he considers to be a
worthy adversary is somebody he will
take on that's battle beast right he
lives for the conflict he's like a
spartan right from the days on earth or
maybe even somebody worse than the
spartans he just lives to fight the
funny thing about this is literally this
fight is like two seconds long if that
he attacks thrag thrag spins his head on
his on his neck and then throws him away
and that's the end of battle beast right
like at the moment like like battle base
is basically taken out by thrag like
that and that's a crazy thing because
when you look at battle beasts as a
character he overpowered mark right even
omniman would struggle with with battle
beast because of how powerful he was but
thrag just overpowers him in an instant
now the other part of this is alan the
alien and space racer right these two
guys are still here from the coalition
of worlds but at the end of the day they
have to kind of bail out of here right
because you still have some vulture
mites that are alive around there and
the reality is even though they're still
capable they're overpowered right so if
they were to stay and they were to fight
they would die and so ultimately it's
kind of like okay let's let's get out of
here they asked the question what do we
do about nolan and mark and the response
to space racer is we gotta leave them
man like we gotta leave them here like
like they can hold their own but if we
stay here we're gonna die right we have
to get back to the coalition we have to
let them know that uh the thaddeus has
been killed right the leader of the
coalition of planets is dead we have to
find some way to reorganize things
because this war is far from over right
so switch back over to thrag right to
freddie mercury and to nolan and mark
right this guy is still crushing him and
that's the funny thing is mark asks his
dad he asked no one like how do we beat
this guy and the response of nolan is we
can't we cannot defeat thrag like it's
one of those rare instances when nolan
is like there's no way for us to win
right the nature of nolan is like he
always finds a way to win right he keeps
fighting and fighting and fighting doing
whatever it is that he has to do but
he's like there's no way for us to
overpower this guy right like in order
for thrag to be made region of the
viltromite empire he's been trained from
birth right he's been made the strongest
out of all of us and he's been educated
in every manner of physical combat
simply put there's no conceivable way
for us to beat this guy by ourselves
this man was literally designed to to
conquer the vulture might race if it
came to it right to take out his own
people he was designed for that right he
was trained for that this guy is a
one-man army he's more than enough to
take out the two of us and so ultimately
like you kind of have omni man who tells
mark like look no matter what's happened
over the course of my life it's
important that you know i've always
loved you he's basically saying his
goodbyes right he tells mark get out of
here right he ends up like telling mark
to get out of here as fast as he
possibly can and mark does he does
exactly as instructed he races off now
mark's not doing this because he's a
coward mark's doing this because he
trusts his father if his father says we
cannot defeat this man on our own you
need to leave then mark leaves knowing
that his father might die in the ensuing
conflict now the other part of this i'll
be honest mark's probably kind of crap
in his pants a little bit just a smidge
right but at the end of the day thrag
still manages to get his hands on him
and then just starts pummeling this guy
now nolan shows up right omniman comes
racing back but this is a testament to
the speed of of thrag here right nolan
comes racing up right because remember
there's no sound in space you can't hear
anything so nolan comes racing up on
thrag and thrag just senses it out of
the corner of his eye and immediately
turns around just in time and impales
omniman right just punches a hole in the
stomach now he goes to kill him and this
is an important thing he goes to kill
them and then he stops he doesn't kill
mark and he doesn't kill nolan the funny
thing is he could have he could have
killed both of them and and something to
know here he's doing all this without
breaking a sweat he's not drawing any
like they're not drawing any blood on
him right they're not like they're not
injuring this guy right like he's just
overpowering them in the most extreme
way ever when the other realtor might
show up and they say why are you sparing
them the responsive thrag is we need
them right there are so precious few of
us realtor mites left we need them we
need people to to basically function as
part of the vulture might empire now the
initial response here is no right we
need vulture mites but we need those who
are loyal the response of thrag is no it
doesn't matter right like if we are
going to survive all of this we need
viltrumites but we need them more than
anybody else which is really kind of
thrags saying like they're the more most
powerful of the villager might exist
right more powerful than anybody else
here there is a kind of subtlety and
there is something else going on behind
the scenes as to why that's the case and
in fact you know what kind of cross that
bridge when we get to it but ultimately
nolan and mark are saved by a coalition
ship which basically brings them on
board you know takes them back to
telestria the coalition of worlds all
that kind of stuff and a few things have
happened right a couple weeks have
passed since they've been picked up and
and mark is just now waking up of course
again nolan recovers faster than mark
does but something to notice here mark's
recovering at a much faster rate than he
previously used to but a couple things
happened one because thaddeus was killed
alan the alien took his place as the
leader of the coalition of worlds the
second thing that's going on here is
that once he takes mark to meet with
nolan you actually end up finding out
that oliver is basically being brought
back now it is kind of a plot device
here if we're being honest with
ourselves oliver basically should have
been dead right i mean he doesn't have
the ability to breathe in space as long
as anybody else does his arm was ripped
off he was rendered unconscious but the
response was given here by nolan is well
you know the vulture right brain can
survive without oxygen longer than
pretty much any other brain out there so
it was he was you know he'd survived by
the skin of his teeth i mean if we're
being honest with ourselves this is
robert kirkman just kind of rolling with
it and just saying like you know insert
excuse here for why oliver continues to
survive but of course a kind of uh
prosthetic arm is being built for him or
being attached to him and then skin will
be grafted over it so he will be able to
feel the difference but nobody else will
see the difference right the other thing
that's going on here is that of course
oliver is healing but a big part of
what's happening is that the planet the
coalition of planets is hunting for the
vulture might race but they don't
understand what's going on right they
don't really understand what's happening
here and the reason why is when the
question is asked by mark like what do
you mean like like they're not they're
not doing anything right because alan
the alien's like they're not attacking
right like they're doing absolutely
nothing like we can't find them at all
we don't know where they are right
they're not here anywhere in this galaxy
we can't find them anywhere in existence
we don't know what's happening right
we've been searching and searching and
we can't find them anywhere we don't
know if they're laying low we don't know
exactly what's going on nothing that
we're seeing makes any sense at all and
then it dawns on mark oh my god and when
the question's like what are you talking
about he's like okay so thrag left us
alive for a reason he could have killed
us but he left us alive for a reason but
they didn't just give up and go into
hiding that's not what velcro might do
velcromites don't just give up they
don't hide they don't run from the
threat they've always got a goal so he's
like if he could have destroyed us and
he didn't then what if the goal here is
to destroy what's closest to us and
that's when everybody starts to realize
what's going on and mark speaks up and
says you can't find them in this galaxy
allen because they're not in this galaxy
they're in the milky way galaxy guys
they're going to earth with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end
cliffhangers thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace
you